Ali is in charge of the dinner menu for
his senior prom and he wants to use a
one-sample Z interval to estimate what
proportion of seniors would order a
vegetarian option he randomly selects 30
of the 150 total seniors and finds that
seven of those sampled would order the
vegetarian option which conditions for
constructing this confidence interval
did ali's sample meet so pause this
video and you can select more than one
of these all right now let's work
through this together so one thing that
you might be wondering is well what is a
one sample Z interval well you could
really interpret that as he's gonna take
one sample and then construct a
confidence interval based on that the
reason why it might be called a Z
interval is the whole idea behind a
confidence interval is you're going to
pick a number of standard deviations
above and below the true parameter that
you are actually trying to estimate and
then use that to make your inferences
and a one way of thinking about the
number of standard deviations people
will often call that a z-score or a Z is
often used as a variable for the number
of standard deviations above or below
something so really he's just trying to
construct a confidence interval but
remember in order to construct a
confidence interval we have to make some
assumptions he's taking there's a
hundred fifty students right over here
he's finding it impractical to survey
all hundred fifty to figure out the true
population proportion so instead he
samples 30 of the seniors so n is equal
to 30 and from that he calculates a
sample proportion and looks like seven
out of the 30 are they want the
vegetarian option and he's going to
determine some confidence level and then
you construct a confidence interval but
remember the conditions that we've
talked about in previous videos the
first thing is we have to be confident
that is this a random sample so that
would be the random condition and that's
what choice a is telling us the data is
a random sample from the population of
interest do we know that well it tells
us in the passage here he randomly
selects 30 of the total seniors so I
guess we'll take their word for it we
don't know his methodology of what he
considers random but
we'll take their word for it that yes
this has been met the data is a random
random sample if it said he sampled the
football team well that would not have
been a random sample the next condition
here it looks all mathematical but this
is really the normal condition and the
idea behind the normal condition is that
in order to construct these confidence
intervals we're assuming that the
sampling distribution of the sample
proportions is roughly normal and it is
not skewed to the right or skewed to the
left like this and so right here it says
look the sample size times our sample
proportion has to be greater than or
equal to 10 or our sample size times 1
minus our sample sample proportion has
to be greater than or equal to 10 well
another way to think about this is our
successes our successes in our sample
need to be greater than or equal to 10
and our failures need to be greater than
or equal to 10 well how many successes
were they there were seven seven and you
could even say look our n is thirty
times our sample proportion is seven
over 30 which is going to be seven so
our set our successes is less than 10
so actually we violate the normal
condition and once again this is a rule
of thumb but this is telling us that our
actual sampling distribution might be
skewed remember this is just based on
one sample what we're able to figure out
this is one samples the interval we
might be wrong but we wouldn't feel good
that we're meeting the normal condition
here so I would rule this one out
individual observations can be
considered independent well if he
randomly selected people with
replacement then they could be
independent or if the people he is
selective if his sample size is less
than 10% of the total population then it
could be considered independent even
though it wouldn't be perfectly
independent but we see here that he
sampled 30 people out of 150 so his
sample size was 30 out of 150 which the
same thing as one-fifth of the
population which is the same thing as
20% and since this is greater than 10%
we are violating the independence
condition we could have met the
independence condition if he was
sampling with replacement which it
doesn't seem like he is or if this thing
right over here was less than 10% but
we're not meeting that so we cannot feel
good about that constraint and so since
we're not meeting two of the three
constraints for I would say valid
confidence intervals or confidence
intervals we would feel confident in
this is not so good of an analysis on
alleys part